hey what's up guys my name is eterno
welcome back to my c++ series so in the
last video I explained why I don't like
using namespace STD if you guys haven't
checked that video out definitely do so
but I haven't actually talked about what
namespaces are in this simple spot
series and because in that video I
specifically wanted to talk about the
standard namespace and why I don't like
using namespace STD but today we're
going to be talking about what
namespaces are in C++ why they're useful
when I would when I wouldn't use them
why they exist and all the different
things that we can do with them
so if we jump right into this this is
the code that we had written in that
previous video where we talked about why
I don't like using namespace everywhere
and all that kind of stuff let's talk a
little bit about what we actually see on
the screen here and how we can further
extend our usage of namespaces and why
main spaces are actually used
unnecessary so over here we essentially
have this issue where we have to print
functions now they do have different
signatures one of these takes in a
string one of these takes in a Const are
but if we kind of revert to maybe both
of them taking in a constant R so if I
change this string 1 to actually take in
a concert char pointer like so we kind
of may have an issue if we weren't using
namespaces because these functions are
identical if I just kind of comment out
this namespace Apple line of code here
and the orange one as well suddenly we
have a little bit of an issue if I try
and I'll fix up this error as well if I
try and just compile this by hitting
ctrl f7 you can see over here that I get
an error because it's telling me that
this print function that takes in the
constructor already has a body because I
have two symbols with the same name and
they're identical symbols
now when I say symbols I'm talking about
things like classes functions variables
constant that kind of that kind of thing
right so we have in this case two
functions called print which take in
constructor and return void they have
the same signature so these two symbols
are identical we can't have two
identical symbols that's a linking error
and potentially a compilation error in
there if they're actually in the same
file so how do we fix that what if we do
want to have to print functions or what
if we use another library that has
already defined a print function but we
want to have our own print function now
back in the days of C and in fact that
still is a thing C doesn't have
namespaces which is why if you would
have noticed in the OpenGL series as an
example we're using a library called GL
FW which is an OpenGL kind of windowing
and context library and in putting all
that kind of stuff right but the point
is jello W is a C is a C library it's
compatible with both C and C++ because
it's a library they can't use namespaces
which is why if you notice in that
series all of the code that we write
that has something to do with JFW
begins with like literally every
function starts with GL FW and then like
the function name for example gel W in
it or jail of W create window all of
that stuff has jelf W literally
prepended to the front of it with opengl
it's kind of the same thing as well we
have GL and then the symbol name so like
GL begin GL & GL j and vertex buffers
that kind of thing right we have an app
deed the actual name of the library or
some kind of ID embedded into the
function name so in our code that will
be the equivalent of if I had literally
written something like Apple print right
and orange print and then now you can
see that I okay these two functions are
different because this is like the Apple
print version this is the orange print
version and that's actually what C
libraries tend to do because they can't
just you know I can't make a function
just called Ahmet because in it is such
a common name what if you know if every
library was to do it was to just name
their functions in it then you could
never use those libraries together
without having to modify the source code
so what they do usually is just kind of
prepend
the name of library to it so J of W in
it and that works because well it's a
fairly unique name right delft w in it
okay cool that's specific to that G of W
library now in C++ instead of us having
to do all this we have namespaces to
solve that issue the primary purpose of
namespaces is to avoid naming conflicts
that's why they exist to avoid naming
conflicts okay
that's it
sort of just if you've getting confused
by why namespaces exist or why they're
being used it's because of naming we
want to be able to call symbols the same
name in different contexts so if we go
back here into Apple print instead of
having this what we can do is enclose
this symbol in a namespace in this case
what we write is namespace the name of
the namespace and then just as if it was
any kind of function we surround it with
curly braces which everything in
everything in between these curly
brackets is included in that Apple
namespace now personally I like to write
my curly bracket on the same line as the
actual namespace declaration I don't
like doing this the reason that happens
is because when we have multiple nested
namespaces it gets a little bit messy so
what I like to do is if we had Apple and
then maybe like functions or something
you know I have this here and also with
the end braces instead of kind of
writing it this way which is what Visual
Studio will try and try and order
formatted to I like to just have it on
the same line that way my actual
functions are one level indented and not
like 2 or 3 or 4 or depending on how
many namespaces we actually have nested
so that's just my personal preference
you don't have to follow that but that's
why I kind of put all this stuff on the
same line so that being said we now have
a have an Apple print function I've
grabbed it here into orange and get rid
of these comments as well we have this
orange print function I can rename it to
just print so we're able to have two
functions with exactly the same
signature in this file and when it comes
time to call it what we do is we need to
specify which one way we need to call so
print is now inside either the apple or
the orange namespace we have two of them
so if we want to use the one from Apple
we just type Apple : : and then print
this : : is essentially like a namespace
operator
so what you do is every kind of
namespace that you go as you drill down
into a namespace you just put a call and
: and that is what I guess enters into
that namespace or allows you to call
things from that namespace the same
thing applies to static functions I
guess or symbols in classes and like
methods and classes and all that stuff a
class is kind of like a namespace it is
it is a namespace of its own which is
why if we're accessing like an inner
class inside
the class or like an enum or you know
like I gave the example of like static
functions or even non static functions
in some cases we use : : so that's what
the : : kind of means so this double
colon is used to get the print function
from the apple and if we were to run
this we would just get holo printing
normally if I want to call the orange
one obviously I type in orange now that
whole using namespace thing that we
talked about in the last episode was
just a way to not have to write this
kind of apple or orange kind of prefix
so instead of having to do this what we
can say is that actually we're using
namespace Apple which means that
basically import everything from the
namespace Apple as if I had never
specified it as a namespace so in this
case print will be used from Apple if I
want I can change it to orange I can
also say if we have multiple things in
here like we have print and maybe print
out an O print again or something if I
have multiple functions maybe I don't
want to use print again from orange I
just want to throw that as an apple
let's go to using namespace apple maybe
I don't want print again when I put this
easy name space I don't want to use
print again I still want to specify
maybe which print again I want I just
want print to be important so to do that
we can just write using Apple and then
the function name print okay that means
that we're going to take this from the
Apple namespace specifically but for
this we'd still have to specify that
namespace like that you can also create
aliases for namespaces by just typing in
namespace you know a equals Apple or
something like that that means I can
type in a print like that instead of
having to spell out Apple that's very
useful for when you have nested
namespaces so we can also nest and
namespaces as you probably saw earlier
so we can have Apple and maybe we
include all about function and we can
close all about functions inside the
dysfunctions namespace for some reason
you can ask me why just an example so we
have namespace apple we have nowadays
functions and then instead of us having
to write you know Apple functions like
that or you know something like using
using namespace
Apple function
like this we could also by the way for
this example you can also split this up
so you can be like using access apple
and using namespace functions which
would allow us to not have to specify
any namespace for print at all
so instead of us having to do this or in
the other example that we can also just
say namespace a equals Apple functions
which means that I can just type in a
print as if it wasn't one namespace and
I would get that result over there okay
so that's a pretty basic example of town
namespaces work I'm not sure if there's
really anything else that I need to talk
about obviously things like things like
this are confined to the actual scope so
in other words a this namespace a equals
Apple functions only exists within this
main function I can't access to the
outside
my recommendation is when you do things
like this like namespace a equals blah
blah or using namespace whatever my
recommendation is you try and confine it
to a smaller scope as possible if you
just need it inside an if statement for
example you know right you write your
declaration inside that if statement if
you just need it inside a function then
writing inside the function and then as
a last result as a last resort write it
in there like kind of in a top-level
file but don't try and like just you
know declare it in at the top level at
all times or in header files certainly
never do it in header files the reason
we don't want to do that is because when
we get you know if we start using
namespace everywhere then as you can
probably imagine that kind of undoes all
of the helpful work that namespaces do
by avoiding naming conflicts because if
we're using it what's the point of
having our functions in namespaces if we
have to if we if we use namespace anyway
right it imports everything which means
that we might as well not be using
namespaces and we can get back to the
problem of having naming conflicts
between libraries or between our and
code so that's just a few things to
think about I've left a link below to
the cpp reference page on namespaces
this has a few examples of what you can
actually do so there's also something
called an inline namespace
really just kind of makes everything
available to the parent namespace we
also have since it was lost 17 the
ability to actually specify namespaces
kind of like this so in this case when I
had this functions instead of having to
do namespace Apple then namespace
functions I can actually just write
namespace functions like that be a way
that that's not supported by all
compilers of course and it is a new kind
of C++ thing I recommend you read
through this page if you want to know
everything that you can do with
namespaces I've pretty much covered most
of the useful things obviously the
reason why we use namespaces is kind of
- if we are creating a library of code
or if we just have our project we want
to put it behind a namespace so that we
don't get any naming conflicts that way
I'm free to create any function that I
really want everything in the C++
standard library is behind the standard
STD namespace so obviously you're not
going to get naming conflicts like that
however if you use any kind of C code no
such thing as namespaces which means
that when you do use C code you are
potentially risking a naming conflict so
even in your C++ project I would still
use a namespace of course because if you
use any C code then that's going to be
an immediate conflict if it has the same
function name as well you're actually
declaring anyway that's namespaces leave
your thoughts below leave your thoughts
on why you use namespaces why you don't
like using main spaces where you would
where you wouldn't all that kind of
stuff I think it's pretty clear that
when you are writing code you should be
writing it behind a namespace if it's
any kind of serious project if you guys
enjoyed this video please hit the like
button you can help support the series
by going over to patreon Ocampo slash
that sure know you'll get access to
videos early and many other awesome
rewards thank you so much to all of the
lovely patrons that helped bring this
series to life it wouldn't be here
without you I will see you guys next
time goodbye
[Music]
you